when you you had to audition for Jack
Skellington The Nightmare Before
Christmas right you auditioned for that
yeah I mean talk about a role that a
gift that keeps on giving hello
boy I mean here's the here's the luck in
my life yeah exactly and that was the
you didn't you just auditioned you
obviously Tim Burton just heard your
voice you didn't meet him right yes and
they they had already done Danny elpin's
songs
so they knew what kind of voice they
were looking for for the speaking part
of Jackson and I guess you know again
Serendipity that I had a vocal Timbre
that that matched Danny's singing and uh
that's it do you do anything with your
voice could you jump into it do you have
a line you could say Eureka
Eureka hello it's Jack
did you have to read twice or one
audition like this is a guy
I just read once
and what was Tim Burton like
uh Tim uh I think people who know the
movie know he didn't direct it that uh
Henry selik directed it wonderful stop
action stop-motion action uh animated
director and then I got together with
Tim after uh for ADR uh for uh looping
uh because he was not satisfied with
some of the line readings and I was not
satisfied with some of my own work and
so I took some notes and I went in and
Tim was very open about you know you
want to make a change here you want to
try this you want to try that uh he was
great he was really and still is I mean
whenever I see him he's you know open
arms and uh he's a lovely guy